tu t'es laver les mains avec du savon
tu les as bien c'est chez beaucoup
d'élus de ces mois sinon est ce qu il
est prévu qu'on en parle un jour croix
du sujet tabou évidemment que le sujet
tabou du nouveau travail de maman il est
temps grand temps de réparer nos erreurs
aidez nous à faire sortir de l'ombre
tous les supers nous deux
changer l'opinion des gens sur les
super-héros et pour cela élastique girl
est notre meilleur atout meilleur que
moi
alors marc cherry le mans cup les
enfants pas quand même c'est pas comme
ça qu'il faut faire papa le produit
qu'on veut utiliser cette méthode je
connais pas cette méthode est pourquoi
ils changent les matches les vagues
scélérates
mais ma démarche est très bien je perds
c'est soit limpide de dolus tence et
jacquet est très en forme c'est quoi ça
ok jackyaci whaou
d'accord ça c'est plus bas c'est
complètement fou mon pour aider ma
famille et je dois la quitte t il pour
faire régner la loi de la transgresser
pour nos enfants pour qu'ils puissent
avoir le choix
[Musique]
conditions imminente qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire y'a le feu
aubin
le nautiz rentero ce programme afin de
vous délivrer un message en film en
costumes ça va chauffer j'arrive tout le
dp
[Musique]
la tête en estrie se fait recaler je
croyais qu'on devient député maire
cobol-it fort
en bon se retrouver les super héros sont
hors la loi se faire la bagarre
la sentence est irrévocable veut pas
dire que tu quoi ouais j'ai entendu ça à
la télé ce millionnaire voudrait qu'on
le rencontre il ya un truc de super
héros dans l'air il est temps pour les
super de reprendre du service
il nous faut hélas stickers au revoir
gérer
occupent d enfants est inquiète pas non
c'est pas comme ça que le propose a dit
faire pourquoi il veut qu'on fasse comme
ça mais je sais pas faire comme ça
pourquoi ils veulent changer les maths
les vagues scélérates on ne change pas
les battre partout dans nos villes et
d'odeurs s'endorment on s endort le
réveil il sombre lol sommeil je serais
pas arrivé s'il comptait pas pris le
relais il faut je réussisse pour qu'elle
réussisse
digard
s'ils restent devant que les sétois ses
fils blancs mais je ne veux pas le
nourrir
[Musique]
bien élever l'enfant est un acte
héroïque
c'est tout un art il ya l'art et la
manière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]